c'est un paradoxe que les acteurs du
football français constatent depuis des
années le ballon rond est le sport le
plus pratiqué en france mais il n'est
presque jamais enseigné à l'école
préjugés mauvaise image polémique pour
inverser la tendance l'éducation
nationale et les instances du football
ont décidé de faire la pédagogie du
sport pratiqué par plus de deux millions
de personnes
chacun de nous se posent les mêmes
questions à l'égard du foot c'est à dire
que à la fois on voit bien qu'il ya une
appétence évidente des jeunes pour le
football et en même temps le football
que aussi souffrir d'une certaine
réputation voit le foot professionnel
plus que parfois les richesses d'une
faute amateurs de 100 enseignants du
premier degré et professeur de sport
suivi une formation à clairefontaine un
investissement important pour la
fédération française de football on
avait besoin de réaffirmer les valeurs
du football aussi à l'école et c'est
pour ça que noël le graet a fait le
choix avec son équipe et avec l'ensemble
des salariés et surtout notre direction
technique nationale 2 mais des moyens
humains parce que nos cadres techniques
vont accompagner les enseignants vont
voilà faire la promotion de ce
dispositif dont je vous ai parlé m'ont
euro 2016 faut beau les princesses donc
oui bien sûr ça a un coût très très
conséquente mais c'était une volonté
politique et on s'en réjouit
le football espère rapidement se créer
une place dans l'enseignement sportif à
l'école objectif 2019 et l'organisation
par la france de la coupe du monde
féminine de football